>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good afternoon,
everyone, and thank you all
for coming to the African
Middle-East Division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb,
Chief of the Division,
and I'm delighted to see you all.
We have with us -- I want
to recognize Chris Murphy,
who is the Head of the Near East
Section here for many, many years,
and a colleague, and also Michael
Albin, who was a comrade in arms
when we went to Iraq together.
And he was the Head of the
Anglo-American Acquisitions,
and also Director of
our office in Cairo.
I want just to say a few
words about our division.
Our division is made
up of three sections,
as I think all of you know.
But anyway, this is for the
camera, so I always say that.
The African, the Near East
and the Hebraic Section.
We collect from 78
different countries in Africa,
in the Middle East, in
Central Asia, in the Caucasus,
and we collect materials primarily
in this division, books,
and [inaudible].
But we also have CDs, DVDs,
music, photographs, et cetera,
which are in formats that
we don't usually collect,
because there are other
divisions that have them.
But we do have our own
series of materials,
and of course, we have manuscripts.
We have lithographs.
And I'm mentioning
that in particular,
because this would be part of the
discussion of today's presenter.
These materials, we preserve, we
keep, we share, we serve, but also,
we like to have discussed.
We like to have --
to bring scholars.
We like to have people who have
worked with these materials come
to our reading room and talk
to us about these materials,
about the way they were made,
where they were made,
for whom they were made.
It gives greater depth
to our collections,
and it helps us understand
what we have.
And it helps our patrons also
get a better understanding
of how these materials can
be used, where they are,
how accessible they are, sometimes
how rare they are as well.
So we invite people
to make presentations.
We do displays, and very often, we
have displays in our reading room.
And we show icons that we collect.
We've had major exhibitions,
both the Persian Book exhibit --
we had the Hebraic book exhibit.
We've had actually one on
Afghanistan, and these were letters
that were written by
Afghans to Radio Free Europe
that discussed various issues,
various personal problems
that people -- young people,
older people face in Afghanistan.
It's a unique collection of letters
that we have, in part, scanned,
and that will eventually be
made available digitally online.
But they've already been
organized, collated,
but still not in a
fashion made available.
Afghanistan has been a very
special focus of our collections,
and we have acquired, from the
Afghan Media Research Center
in Kabul, over 95,000 photographs.
That's the largest
collection ever on Afghanistan,
which have been digitized.
Those photographs have
been digitized in Kabul
by the Afghan Media Research Center.
They cover a period from
the late '70s to 2012.
We've got films -- a collection of
films and videos from that center
that are now in our research --
in our motion picture collection.
And we have sound recordings
as well.
That's in addition to the books,
the serials, the journals,
and the lithographs and manuscripts.
I also want to recognize Hirad
Dinavari, who's been in charge
of our Afghan collection, who's
done a fantastic job in organizing
and having a lot of our
materials digitized and reviewed.
And we have here Jan
Lancaster, who, herself,
has gone through all our
manuscripts, Persian manuscripts
and Afghan manuscripts
and lithographs,
and identified the
problems with them.
We have the Preservation
Division here, that has looked
at our materials and advised
us about what to do with them.
So collecting is just the
beginning of the process
by which we integrate the new
collections into our system,
and sharing with us today is
Elham Bakhtary, who has worked
with these materials, and who
will be sharing his research
and his work on these materials.
And to introduce him today
is our own Hirad Dinavari,
our Persian specialist, who
has done tremendous work
in developing the collections
and preserving them.
So I'll pass it on to Hirad.
Thank you.
>> Hirad Dinavari:
Thank you, Mary-Jane,
for a wonderful introduction,
and I want to thank you all
for being here on a busy lunch hour.
I'm sure you would be happier
with food, but I also want
to take a minute and echo what
Mary-Jane mentioned before
introducing our wonderful
speaker, Elham.
This has been a personal passion for
me in the last few years of working
with materials, both manuscripts
and lithograph from the region
in a Persian language, as well
as other regional languages,
especially collections
from Afghanistan.
I'm very delighted to say we have
a good amount of lithographs,
as well as some manuscripts and
early imprints from Afghanistan
that now are being digitized.
I cannot mention enough
how the Upstarts work
with World Digital
Library began the process.
And we have a wonderful
representative, Chris Masciangelo,
here, who worked with us closely as
we identified over 100 Afghan titles
that we digitized for that
project, in Pashtu and in Persian,
Dari Persian, that
are now being used.
And the positive side of that
is researchers like Elham,
who are now coming and are using our
Afghan materials, and are delighted
that this material
is available online.
And whatever did not get under the
-- get done under the WDL project,
in the project we are
doing now, the Persian --
rare Persian language digitization
project, we are now going
to digitize in the next few
years, from the whole region.
Persian materials from
Iran, Afghanistan,
Central Asia, India and beyond.
So with that, I want to take
a minute and introduce Elham.
Elham is a doctoral candidate who
was awarded a Mellon Fellowship
in the past year at the
Library's Preservation Division
to conduct research on early Afghan
lithography and printing press.
He made extensive use of Ahmed's
rare Persian language materials,
lithographic and early imprint,
as well as some Pashtu, and even,
I would say, some regional
publications in Persian
from all over, as well as Arabic
and even Central Asian material.
Prior to beginning his doctoral
program and GW in the fall of 2012,
he completed a B.A. in History
at the University of California,
Davis Campus, where he focused
on Middle Eastern and
South Asian history.
After finishing his undergraduate
work, he went to complete his M.A.
in History in San Francisco State
University, where he began to focus
on Islamic intellectual
thought in the British Empire.
His research draws heavily on
English, Persian and Arabic sources,
and I also want to mention that he
has published an official subaltern
in Islamic modernist narratives
of the first Anglo-Afghan War,
the 44th Annual Conference
on South Asia.
And this was done in Madison,
Wisconsin, produced by them,
Center for South Asian Studies
in Wisconsin University.
Thank you, Elham, and again, I
look forward to working with you.
I hear that Elham will be coming
back soon to do some more work
at the Library, and I am looking
forward to working with you on --
closely on better understanding
and appreciating our Afghan --
rare Afghan collections
here at the Library.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Elham Bakhtary: Thank you,
Mary-Jane, and thank you, Hirad,
for that wonderful introduction.
I want to extend a warm thank-you
to the entire Library of Congress
for having afforded me the
opportunity to do this research.
This has been an incredible
resource, and I've been so fortunate
to be located at an institution so
close by to the Library of Congress.
I wouldn't have been able to do it
without the Library of Congress,
especially the African and
Middle-Eastern Division,
and with the help of
wonderful staff.
I've done research in
England, Afghanistan, India,
and I can tell you for sure that
there's not as helpful of a staff
as the staff here at the
African-Middle-Eastern Division.
So thank you again, Mary-Jane.
Thank you to Joan Weeks, and a
special thank-you to Hirad Dinavari.
He really is the jewel in the
crown of my research, if you will,
and he's been with me
every step of the way.
And I wouldn't be able to do it
without the help of these people.
And the Library of Congress has been
especially helpful when it comes
to the history of print
in Afghanistan.
Now, print began during the
reign of Emir Sher Ali Khan.
Let me pull up the
PowerPoint real quick.
This handsome individual right here.
He -- his reign was split into
two parts, because he was engaged
in a civil war with
his older brothers.
And he was the first one to
actually bring the printing press
to Afghanistan, but we don't
actually have a whole lot
of materials that are in
existence from that time period,
because when the British invaded
Afghanistan in 1878 to dethrone him,
they shelled the Bala
Hissar, his fortress,
where the printing
house was located.
And the printing house was
burned, and subsequently looted.
And so we don't have many
materials from that time period.
Now, the Library of Congress
has shown incredible diligence
in collecting materials, and so
they only have a few materials
from this time period.
But I want you to understand
that this is a huge share
of the materials that exist.
There aren't that many at all.
And so I just want to quickly go
through the ones that I analyzed.
These are just the ones from the
period of Emir Sher Ali Khan.
There are many more
materials from the --
from Afghanistan, from the
reigns of Emir Abdur Rahman Khan,
Emir Habibullah Khan,
and going on forth.
So these are specifically
amongst the first prints
from Afghanistan's
-- from Afghanistan.
And so the first is
[foreign language],
meaning the conclusive argument
invalidating the misleading
Wahabi creed.
The next item is "Shamsa Nihar,"
and we have two issues here
at the Library of Congress,
two original issues.
"Shamsa Nihar" meaning the morning
sun, Afghanistan's first newspaper.
And the last one is
[foreign language],
which means gift to the Ulama.
Now, the first item,
as the title suggests,
is a polemic written
targeting Wahabis.
The second two I would describe
as mirrors for subjects.
These are materials that
are instructing subjects,
including the Ulama, on
how to behave as Muslims,
what are their duties and
obligations as Muslims,
and what are their
obligations to the ruler.
And in this talk, I
will suggest that,
although the Emir's Court
initially used propaganda
to attack the Wahabis,
it was the Wahabis
that inspired these
latter forms of propaganda
in both form and substance.
Now, this project was a
bit difficult to undertake,
since there wasn't much
existing scholarship
on the history of print
in Afghanistan.
There have been some developments
in recent years studying the history
of print in the Middle
East and South Asia.
Unfortunately, Afghanistan
is treated like a square peg
in the study of the
Middle East and South Asia,
so much of this scholarship --
or, almost all of this
scholarship doesn't really touch
on Afghanistan at all.
And there have been recent
developments in the study
of Afghanistan in the 19th century,
but most of this scholarship
concerns the reign
of Emir Sher Ali Khan's predecessor
and father, Emir Dost Mohammad Khan,
as well as his successor and
cousin, Emir Abdur Rahman Khan.
But Emir Sher Ali Khan
keeps getting skipped over.
So there wasn't really a whole lot
of existing scholarship
for me to work with.
So I want to give a brief
survey of the history
of print during Emir
Sher Ali Khan's reign.
According to colonial sources,
Emir Sher Ali Khan imports
a printing press in 1869,
and that's a lithographic
press, [foreign language],
as it's referred to in Persian.
And he imported this press for
the purpose of printing stamps.
You see in the image on the left of
a 19th century lithographic press
in operation, the operator is
rolling the ink onto the limestone,
and to the right, you see an image
of a stamp from Sher Ali's reign.
And in the center is
actually the image of a lion,
and this was a common symbol
used throughout Emir Sher Ali
Khan's reign.
His name, Sher, meaning lion.
And that he imported the press
to print stamps is telling,
in that it shows that the press
was not originally intended
for propaganda.
It's not until two
years later, actually,
that we have the first
works of propaganda.
So why did he decide to start
using the press for propaganda?
Well, to answer that question,
we look at the first works
of propaganda, both of which
were religious polemics targeting
the Wahabis.
Now, these are not the Wahabis
you might be thinking of,
the Arabian Wahabis founded by
Muhammad ibn Abd al-Wahhab of Najd.
This is actually referring
to the Tariqah-i-Muhammadiyah
who were a militant revivalist
movement founded in India
by Syed Ahmad of Raebareli,
and Shah Ismail of Delhi.
And they were a militant
revivalist movement,
and they were called Wahabis because
of the similarity of their ideas
and actions to the Arabian Wahabis.
But they actually had
no organizational ties.
The actual forerunner to the
movement was a contemporary
of Mohammad ibn Abd al-Wahhab.
They were actually
born in the same year,
and his name was Shah
Wali Allah of Delhi.
And Shah Wali Allah of Delhi,
we could describe more or less
as a salafi, meaning someone
who believed that the society
of the Prophet Mohammed and the
Rashidun Caliphate were a model
for contemporary Muslims, and
that contemporary Muslims could
and should emulate that society.
And they would do that by
purging themselves of innovations
that had cropped into the
religion since that time period.
And some of these innovations, the
ones that he went after the most,
were what he referred
to as pseudo-Sufi practices
in society at large.
Oh, sorry.
It's a little high.
Okay. Sorry about that.
So, some of the practices
that he went after he referred
to as pseudo-Sufi practices
that were common throughout
British India.
And these practices revolved around
Sufi saints, both past and present,
and these included acts like asking
saints for intercession between them
and God, shrine-oriented worship,
the wearing of towels,
[inaudible] and charms.
And Shah Wali Allah believed that
these practices were very prevalent
because Muslims actually
didn't know the Quran.
Very few Muslims actually
were able to read the Quran,
because of it being in Arabic.
And he believed that
if they knew the Quran,
they wouldn't be doing
these practices.
If they actually knew what the
contents of the Quran were,
they would immediately
stop all these kind
of shrine-oriented
activities and what have you.
Now, the issue was, in India
and most of the Islamic world,
it was taboo to translate the Quran.
The consensus was that you
could not translate the Quran
without distorting the meaning.
But Shah Wali Allah, being very
confident in his skills in Arabic
and Persian, decided to translate
the Quran from Arabic to Persian.
And this was really
the first translation
of the Quran in South Asia.
And he translated this
Quran specifically
for Mughal Court officials
and elite military officers.
And my theory is that he did
it just specifically for them
because they were the
decision makers in India.
And he believed that the decline of
Muslim political power in India had
to do with this improper
practice of Islam.
He believed that if you get
the decision makers of India
to practice Islam correctly, they
could understand what Islam --
the true message of Islam was,
and they could potentially
administrate the country better
and right the ship, if you will.
The Tariqah-i-Muhammadiyah
take this message,
but they want to expand
it beyond the court.
They want to take it to the streets,
if you will, and they believed that,
for society to change,
everyone needed to be involved.
It couldn't just be
something that was top-down.
It really had to be
bottom-up to a certain extent.
And scholars theorize that they
believed that this was possible
because of the printing press, okay?
That the printing press
inspired them,
that Shah Wali Allah's
reformation could be expanded
to society at large.
And so they used print
relatively early in their movement.
Starting in 1824, they established
a printing press in Calcutta.
Subsequently, they
established presses in Delhi,
Lucknow, Lahore and other cities.
And they write pamphlets that
almost anyone could understand.
If they couldn't read them,
if they were read to them,
at least they would be able
to understand the language.
And they used a simplified form of
Persian in their initial pamphlets.
Now, when Shah Wali Allah wrote,
he wrote in Arabic and Persian,
and he wrote in a very sophisticated
form of Arabic and Persian.
So even if it was read to you,
you might not actually understand
what he was talking about,
but they wrote with
the masses in mind.
And eventually, they
started writing in Urdu,
which was a spoken language
among some Indian Muslims.
So it was not just simply an
acquired language like Persian was.
This is an image of a
Tariqah publication.
This is a work by Shah Abdul Aziz,
who was actually not a
member of the Tariqah.
He was the son of Shah Wali Allah,
and he was revered by the Tariqah.
And so they made efforts
to publish his work.
This one, [foreign language],
and most of their lithographs
look like this.
And you kind of see the
variety of scripts being used,
[foreign language]
here, and so this kind
of gives you the idea
of what they look like.
But most of their publications,
especially their initial
publications,
were works that were dedicated
to attacking the pseudo-Sufism
that Shah Wali Allah spoke of.
And the most important work
in the initial period is a
work called [foreign language],
"The Strengthening of
Faith," by Shah Ismail.
So in this book, he
goes after these rituals
that he considers innovations,
[foreign language] in Islam,
but he also challenges
traditional theological positions.
And what he does is, he accuses
scholars, past and present,
of having put limits on God's power.
He says that they mistake the
impossibility of God doing something
for being the inability
of God to do something.
He gives the case, for example,
that although God would
not create another prophet,
Mohammed being the final
prophet, God still has the ability
to create another prophet,
even another Mohammed.
Thousands of Mohammeds, if he wills.
This sets off a firestorm
of debate in India.
Some of the established Ulama,
like, flipped their lid over this,
and this debate rages
on for three decades,
and even continues
to this day, really.
I mean, you can go on forums today,
and people are still having
these kinds of arguments.
But really, from the 1830s to
the 1860s, all kinds of works,
massive volumes, are being
written about this subject.
Now, Kabul, Afghanistan wasn't
really involved in these debates,
but that didn't mean that they
weren't aware of these individuals.
Emir Sher Ali Khan's father
actually, on two occasions,
had military alliances with
the Tariqah-i-Muhammadiyah.
So the Tariqah-i-Muhammadiyah
actually established a militant wing
in the frontier between
the Punjab and Afghanistan.
And the reason they did this is
because, in the early 19th century,
the Sikhs had taken over
the city of Peshawar,
and they had banned Muslims
there from consuming beef
and performing the Adhan,
the public call to prayer.
And the Tariqah had said that
these were grounds for jihad,
and therefore they went there,
and they set up a base
to fight the Sikhs.
And the Afghans were
interested in fighting the Sikhs
because they had last
Peshawar to the Sikhs.
And so they found common
ground, and they allied.
But it doesn't seem like they really
had any theological discussions
in all this chaos, jihad
being the priority.
The effort fails.
Syed Ahmad and Shah Ismail are both
killed in 1831, and the Afghans give
up on their attempt
to take back Peshawar.
However, in 1839, when the
British invaded Afghanistan
to dethrone Emir Dost
Mohammad Khan, again,
they strike up another
brief alliance.
Hundreds of Tariqah members go
to the city of Ghanzi to help put
up a stand with the locals
there, and that fails, as well.
And, according to reports, they
all returned back to the frontier.
So none of them remain
in Afghanistan.
And Kabul doesn't really hear
about them much until 1871.
And, according to those sources,
they state that in that year,
or sometime before, some Punjabi
and Peshawari Ulama had forwarded
a request to the Kabul Court
for a refutation of the Tariqah's
beliefs, and the Tariqah's doctrine.
Which raises the question, why would
they send this to the Kabul Court?
There had already been volumes
of works refuting these
individuals' ideas,
authored by well-respected scholars,
scholars that were more imminent
than anyone in Kabul,
including Maulana Hidaboudi
[assumed spelling].
My theory is that,
traditionally, if you read the works
in Islamic scholasticism by
authors like Imam Ghazali
or Fakhr al-Din al-Razi,
they make it very clear
that it's the prerogative of the
Islamic ruler to deal with heretics.
It's the Islamic ruler that
has to commission the Ulama
to right heresiographies.
It's the job of the Ulama to
administer the punishment,
whether that be humiliating them,
imprisoning them, or executing them.
And the problem for
the Punjabi Ulama is
that the British rule India,
and they thus cannot give those
refutations the official stamp
of approval that was
traditionally required.
Emir Sher Ali Khan was the
nearest independent Muslim ruler
to the Punjab, and it helped that
he had a printing press as well.
Therefore, he was the natural
choice to commission these works.
And so, two refutations were issued
from the Kabul Court
in the same year, 1871.
And so, the work on the
left is [foreign language],
the one I mentioned earlier.
This one was a scholarly work.
It was authored by
Maulana Abdur Rahman,
who was the Chief Kazi [assumed
spelling] during the reign
of Emir Sher Ali Khan, and
it's in Persian and Arabic.
It uses a lot of classic text,
scholarly sources, a lot of logic.
The source on the right is [foreign
language], "The Piercing Flame."
This one was actually
authored by the Emir himself,
and it was not scholarly at all.
And the Emir explains
in the tract as to why.
He states, "In this tract, I
have not entered into discussion
of many Islamic sciences.
I believe the Ulama in every country
have already crafted responses
to this [foreign language],
this disbelief.
But because those writings
include scientific terminology,
the masses cannot understand them.
Hence, it is not the
Ulama that are falling
into the claws of these owls.
Rather, the hunt of these enslavers
is after the mice who are ignorant.
This is a teeth-shattering response
to the infidels that no one has
yet to give, which will
render the infidels
without the strength
and ability to speak."
And what's interesting about
that work is how much it mirrors
Tariqah literature.
The Tariqah, they would focus
on the Quran and Hadith.
They wouldn't really use
the other materials --
auxiliary materials for
understanding Quran, you know,
these Tasfird [assumed
spelling] and so forth.
They would try to make it all
about the Quran and Hadith.
And if you look at the difference
in materials that are used
in "Hijat a Kawia"
[assumed spelling] versus
"Shihadist al Qib"
[assumed spelling],
the ones I have listed here
for Hijat [assumed
spelling] are just a fraction.
There are actually many
more sources that are used.
But in "Shahab es Alqib" [assumed
spelling] there are only two sources
used, and they're not
even really cited.
They're just kind of mentioned.
Like, I'm not a crazy
man making all this up.
If you want to read further,
you can find these ideas
in the Tasfird [assumed spelling]
and Eshapudi [assumed spelling]
and Albezawi [assumed spelling].
So otherwise, the text is
really very similar to the kinds
of literature that are
produced by the Tariqah,
such as "Taquiet el
Iman" [assumed spelling].
It's written for society at large,
and it's written in
accessible language.
And the Emir informs the reader
that he did this intentionally.
"For the honor of the strong
Mohammed religion, I have decided
to present in some plain words, in
simple, fluent Persian, the beliefs
and opinions held by
these unfortunate people."
And so, he was essentially combating
Tariqah propaganda with the same --
with a similar structure, if you
will, fighting fire with fire.
Now, interestingly, after these
polemics, the Emir decides
to produce more propaganda,
not to go after the Tariqah --
he actually never mentions them ever
again in the remaining publications.
Who he does go after is
Afghanistan's own Ulama,
and I suggest that, although
both of these texts went
after the Tariqah viciously,
the Emir learned
from the Tariqah just how
effective print propaganda could be
in changing the minds of society,
and challenging recalcitrant Ulama.
The Tariqah had really
shaken the authority
of the traditional Ulama in India.
They had drawn tens of
thousands of followers,
including seminary students,
away from imminent Ulama.
Some prominent scholars
even became members.
As a result, some member --
some major mosques were reoriented
towards Tariqah doctrine.
The Tariqah also inspired
the non-militant Deobandi
and Ahl al-Hadith movements, which
today are major schools of thought
in India, throughout South Asia,
and including Afghanistan as well.
Now, why was the Emir interested
in challenging the Ulama?
Historically, the Ulama in
Afghanistan were central
to the legitimacy of the Shahs
and Emirs, also instrumental
in conscripting volunteers
to support them
in civil wars, or foreign invasions.
Now, the Emir really needed
their help, because he was trying
to centralize the government,
primarily through a
central, modern army.
And the problem was that a lot
of Ulama were financially
independent of the Emir.
They really didn't need
his support, and in turn,
they really didn't have any need to
give him support for this project.
They had other sources of patronage.
Tribal chieftains, local
rulers, even the Emir's brothers,
who were rival claimants
to the throne.
And these reforms threatened to
disenfranchise the Ulama's patrons
of their traditional military
authority and revenue.
Historically, these chieftains and
rulers provided military levies
to the Shahs and Emirs in
exchange for revenue and autonomy,
but the Emir was looking
to circumvent them
and reduce them to pensionaries.
And so the Ulama, almost
like representatives,
articulated opposition
to the Emir's reforms,
but rather than cry
disenfranchisement,
they made a religious argument
that the Emir's reforms
were actually innovations,
[foreign language], with
no precedent in Islam.
Therefore, the Emir was in need of
a way to respond to that argument,
and after the Wahabi debates,
he begins printing materials
that targeted that opposition.
So we look at some of the
latter forms of propaganda,
and this is the cover from an issue
of "Shamsa Nihar,"
"The Morning Sun."
"Shamsa Nihar" was
Afghanistan's first newspaper,
but it was more --
really like a gazette.
The earliest issue we have in
existence is from November 6, 1873.
That's number five.
This here is number
seven, which is housed here
at the Library of Congress.
And this newspaper only has
a run of about three years.
And my theory is that it was founded
on the Emir's intelligence network.
The newspaper talks
about, for example,
having foreign correspondents, but
these correspondents were actually
in the same locations the Emir
would send envoys and diplomats to.
And so I feel like these were --
these were likely the same people
that were sending the
reports back to the Emir
on the ongoing [foreign language],
and then once the Emir was
done looking at these reports,
he would then forward them to
the office of "Shamsa Nihar."
Of course, edited for any
sensitive information.
Now, when it came to
news around the world,
the Emir didn't have agents
beyond the neighboring countries
of Afghanistan, but what he
relied on were foreign newspapers,
especially British
Indian newspapers.
And I've provided here
a table of some
of the newspapers that were used.
There were many more that
were cited in "Shamsa Nihar."
But you can see that
these newspapers come
from many different parts of India,
Qureshi, Lehore, Bombay, Calcutta.
You get a pretty good spread there.
In different languages,
Persian, English, and Urdu,
and also there were a few newspapers
that have come from London itself,
including "The Illustrated
London News."
And "Shamsa Nihar" had a staff
to translate these materials.
There were a few people there
that were educated in English.
They had mostly been brought
over from British India
to work specifically
in this respect.
And so, although these -- although
"Shamsa Nihar" would
reprint these stories --
and they were clearly not original
stories in "Shamsa Nihar" --
the selection of them
is quite interesting.
There was news from
all over the world.
For example, they would talk about
some of the wars that were going
on in Europe, such as the
Carlist wars in Spain.
They would also talk a lot about
imperialism going on in the rest
of the world -- Dutch
Imperialism in East Asia,
British Imperialism in West Africa.
And so it really pushed the idea
that imperialism was a
problem throughout the world,
and that Afghanistan likewise was
under a threat, both by the Russians
and eventually by the
British as well.
There were also articles on science,
and articles for general knowledge.
There's an article
about the Pacific Ocean,
just explaining what the
Pacific Ocean is, how big it is,
what are some of its features.
But most importantly, there
were a number of think pieces
in "Shamsa Nihar," and these were
reflections on the news items,
or they were printed
speeches of the Emir,
or his Chief Secretary Kazi Abdul
Khadr Khan [assumed spelling].
Or they might've been --
even been original articles.
But all of them had the common theme
of enjoining the Emir's subjects
to take the example of other
countries, and pursue knowledge,
and show dedication and
loyalty to the Emir.
And many of these think pieces
also contained criticism
of the country's Ulama,
and responding
to the opposition of
the country's Ulama.
There was even a book published in
1875 specifically for this task,
this book being called [foreign
language], "Gift to the Ulama."
And you can see it's in
pretty rough condition.
These lithographs have
been through wars,
going back to the Second
Anglo-Afghan War,
and up to the present
war today in Afghanistan.
So I know they look rough,
but just try to understand
that they've seen a
lot of destruction.
And this work -- it opposes
the Ulama in a similar way
to how the Tariqah
opposed the Ulama of India.
And my dissertation will look
at the ways both "Shamsa Nihar"
and [foreign language]
used the discursive methods
of Tariqah literature.
But for now, I just want to
discuss -- for the time remaining,
I wanted to discuss the
staff that was involved
in the production of
these lithographs.
And we don't have a
lot of info about them.
The British weren't very interested
in the press in Afghanistan,
at least not until they started
producing materials talking
about jihad.
Once they started producing
materials about jihad,
then they started paying
a little closer attention.
But we don't really have much
knowledge about the staff
that actually operated the
press, and was responsible
for creating these materials.
All we know is what we can gather
from these materials themselves.
And it's -- very interesting is
that we see a very clear Shia
and Iranian element in the
production of these lithographs.
For example, the two
works against the Wahabis,
"Hijat a Kawia" [assumed spelling]
and "Shahab es Alqib"
[assumed spelling],
were produced by a man named
Mirza Mohammed Saldit ab Izi
[assumed spelling].
Now, that he was from
Tabriz is not a surprise,
because Tabriz was the first
site of printing in Iran,
both for typography and lithography.
And Tabrizis would go to other
parts of the Islamic world,
establish presses and newspapers.
The newspaper "Akhtar"
in Istanbul, for example,
was founded by a Tabrizi.
And there was a Tabrizi diaspora
throughout the Ottoman Empire,
also in parts of India.
So the fact that Mirza Mohammed
Saldit [assumed spelling] was
from Tabriz, and probably
helped found the printing press
in Afghanistan and operate it,
shouldn't be that surprising.
There was another Iranian associated
with the production of this work,
"Tu Fatul Ulama" [assumed spelling],
Mirza Baizahan Shirazi
[assumed spelling],
and Shiraz also had printing
established there long
before Afghanistan.
So it probably appears that
the Emir sought out people
that could help run the press.
Since Afghanistan had not
had a press before his reign,
there was no one there really
adequately trained to operate it,
and so he needed to import labor
that was familiar with that.
With "Shamsa Nihar," interestingly,
though, the name that is associated
with it as the director and editor
is Mirza abd el Ali [assumed
spelling], and he does not have
a nispa [assumed spelling].
He is not identified
with a city in Iran.
So my guess is that he was
Kizilbash, of the Kizilbashia,
Kizilbash community in Afghanistan
who had a long history in that area,
since of the time of Nader
Shah Afsharid, as mercenaries,
and then later as mirzas,
secretaries and clerks.
And he was put in charge
specifically of "Shamsa Nihar,"
and its content, and editing it.
I'm not sure if he was actually
involved in the process of producing
"Shamsa Nihar," but it's
possible that he learned it
from Mirza Mohammed Sald et
Tarbrizi [assumed spelling]
or Mirza Baizah Han Sher
Azi [assumed spelling].
Now, it's interesting how this
Shia individuals are helping the
production of works that are
challenging the Tariqahalan Ulama.
And it appears that their
religious beliefs might have risked
discrediting the authority
of the materials produced.
And what was interesting as I was
going through them, I noticed that,
in the kalathan [phonetic] of
Shihab es Alhib [assumed spelling],
the one authored by Emir Sher Ali
Khan, you read [foreign language],
"by the effort of Mirza Mohammad
Sal et Tabrizi [assumed spelling]."
However, in the kalathan
[assumed spelling]
for "Hijat a Kawia"
[assumed spelling],
we see [foreign language].
The Tabrizi was left
out, interestingly.
And the author of "Hijat a
Kawia" [assumed spelling] was an
established Alim in
Afghanistan, a traditional Alim,
Maulana Abdur Rahaman Khan.
His father had actually written
heresiographies against the Shias
of Iran during the Kadjar Sarazai
[assumed spelling] over Heerat
in the early 19th century.
And so, it seems that
he actually requested
that the Tabrizi be left out,
because it would be a dead giveaway
that a Shia was involved in
the production of this work.
And that would highly
discredit its authority, almost.
However, the Emir left it in, and
it kind of shows you the difference
in mentalities between the Emir and
a traditional Alim in Afghanistan.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And the styling.
>> Elham Bakhtary:
And the style, yeah.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Very different, yeah.
Absolutely.
Yeah. [Foreign language] Absolutely.
So I hope this gave you some
understanding of the origins
of print in Afghanistan,
and I look forward
to any questions you might have.
>> Hirad Dinavari: I have
[inaudible] question.
A lot of what you were examining,
these [inaudible] prints, binding,
things of that sort, and I know
that you didn't have enough
time to focus on that.
But just to give an overview,
what did you find from looking
at all these Afghan and
other regional lithographs?
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Could you repeat
the question for the [inaudible]?
>> Elham Bakhtary: Okay.
Okay. So Hirad is referencing my
research that I did this past year,
working with the Preservation
Research Testing Division
of the Library of Congress,
and we were trying
to establish the provenance
of the printing press itself,
and of the papers used.
And originally, I was
intrigued by this topic
because of these Iranian staff
members of the printing press,
because Iran really learned
the printing press from Russia.
People were -- had been sent
there to learn the printing press.
They'd imported the
printing press from Russia,
and they also would import
materials from Russia.
So I was curious if -- where
were the materials coming from?
Were they coming more
from British India?
Were they coming from Russia?
Possibly Iran as well, because Iran
started producing its own paper
in this time period as well.
What we discovered is that more
or less, the materials did come
from British India, and we had
a chance to look at a number
of watermarks that
were in some of these,
especially "Hijat a Kawia" [assumed
spelling] and "Shamsa Nihar."
They had wonderful watermarks,
and all of them came
from mills in London.
And we believe that this paper
had been sent to British India,
and then purchased
from British India.
And this is a good indication
that the printing press itself
also came from British India.
It was definitely transported to
Afghanistan through British India,
and it was prob -- it was likely
created in British India as well.
>> Thank you very much
for a very good speech,
and a very [inaudible] subject.
>> Elham Bakhtary: Right, right.
>> Full of questions.
But what about Pashtu publications?
Were there Pashtu publications?
Were the publications sold?
How were they distributed?
In other instances, [inaudible]
primarily in the early days,
where [inaudible] focus of
printing was a modernizing impulse.
This doesn't seem to be
necessarily the case here.
So could you discuss
Pashtu versus Persian,
and how the materials were
distributed and [inaudible]?
>> Elham Bakhtary: Okay.
So in regards to Pashtu,
yes, in this period of time,
the first materials of Pashtu
are being printed as well.
But these were mostly
military manuals
that were translated from English.
The Emir wanted Pashtu to be the
official language of the military.
Which is ironic, because all the
other publications are in Persian.
So this -- you can kind of
see some of the contradictions
that are already starting to emerge
in the ideology of the Afghan state.
And so you have one -- you have
Persian as sort of the language
of culture, the language
of politics and diplomacy,
but on the other hand, you're trying
to make Pashtu the
language of the military.
And there are actually exams being
given in Pashtu as well, so --
and a lot of the generals
and officers
in the military were
actually Kizilbash
who were not really Pashtu speakers.
And so you can kind
of imagine what kind
of tensions these might
have created.
Unfortunately, we don't
have any of these manuals,
these military manuals
that are in Pashtu.
But under Emir Abdur Rahman Khan,
similar manuals were produced,
and those are available.
The British Library
has some of those,
and I had a chance to
look at some of them.
But otherwise, they're really
just straight translations
of the British Indian manuals.
And as far as --
>> Sale, sale.
>> Elham Bakhtary: The
sales of these materials,
I would say that the polemics were
distributed throughout Afghanistan
to provincial rulers, to be read
in public, either in the bazaars
or in the masjids, in the mosques.
As for "Shamsa Nihar," it
was available for purchase.
Actually, info about how to
subscribe was in every issue.
Based on what I understand
about subsequent newspapers
in Afghanistan, and other newspapers
in the region, such as Iran,
usually these newspapers
would be forced upon people
in the government.
And they would be automatically
docked from their pay.
So there was that, but also, in
"Shamsa Nihar," it does mention
that you could -- anyone could
kind of go to a seller of hundis
in Kabul, a [foreign language],
and they could purchase a hundi,
and they would get a subscription
of "Shamsa Nihar" every
week, or every month.
Actually, it was never printed
regularly, but the idea was
that it was going to be printed
every week, at least initially.
And that they could sign
up, and they could get it.
It's not clear if that shop
that gave the hundis also
had individual issues.
It does list the price
of an individual issue,
but we don't really
have much indication
as to whether this was
something that would be sold
on the streets, like
a modern newspaper.
There was also the possibility
of purchasing the newspaper
from British India.
So it gives you instructions
on how to purchase it if you're
in Peshawar, but it's not really
clear how far it was distributed
into India.
You could purchase it from Peshawar,
but we don't really have any info --
idea of how far or
widely it was distributed.
So we could -- we would limit
the readership to the area
of Afghanistan and the
immediate area in British India.
>> One other question, please.
The Ulama had no printing way of
rebutting this, or participating
in print in a debate with the Emir?
>> Elham Bakhtary: Not yet.
No, not yet.
Not the ones in Afghanistan.
The Tariqah had the
capability, and it's interesting
that they don't respond
to these polemics,
at least not that I know of.
And I think that part
of the reason is
because he was the lone independent
Islamic ruler in the area.
This would open up
another can of worms,
if they tried to challenge
him openly about his ideas,
because he really is the
authority on what is orthodoxy.
But they do not challenge him,
and it's not until much later
that you have private
presses in Afghanistan,
well into the 20th century.
>> Hiram Dinavari: One more
thing that came up in the work
that you were doing is, it was
curious that a lot of classics
of Persian literature,
[inaudible], et cetera, were --
we tend to find most of
them are from India, really,
and then partially
Iran and Central Asia.
With the Afghan material, it
seemed that there was an attempt
to make it unique -- the content
and subject uniquely Afghan.
Could you say a few words, as
far as what your theory is,
why these classics which were
obviously used in Afghanistan
and not in Afghanistan were
not being produced [inaudible]?
>> Elham Bakhtary: Right, yeah.
So this is going to be a big
part of my dissertation research,
and most of those ideas
are still in beta mode.
But I will speak to
that a little bit.
So in [inaudible] Iran, for
example, you do have reproductions
of these epic works, of
poets like Hafez-e Shirazi,
of "The Shahnameh" being produced.
You don't have that in Afghanistan.
And my theory is that
the Emir Sher Ali Khan,
when he talks about the history of
Afghanistan, he characterizes it
as a terra nullius of savagery,
that Afghanistan was
basically an unknown land
until he had come to power.
Afghans were ignorant.
Afghans lived in darkness, and
I believe that he did not want
to print these great works
because it would remind people
of Horsani [assumed
spelling] civilization.
It would remind people of a time
that, indeed, there was civilization
in Afghanistan, and it
was certainly better
than anything the Emir was building.
The Emir wanted to portray the
past as simply one of darkness,
because it would sharpen the
contrast of his own rule.
And I believe that, unlike
the Punjabs were trying
to associate their rule with
earlier Iranian dynasties
like the Saffarids, Emir Sher Ali
Khan did not want any association
with any previous rulers,
both in Afghanistan and Islam.
Like the Tariqah, he
actually really tries
to associate his rule most
closely with the Salaf,
with the Prophet Mohammad
and the Rashidun Caliphate.
That's really the history that
he tries to attach his rule,
and that's how -- and that's
one of the connections I'm going
to be trying to draw between the
Tariqah and Emir Sher Ali Khan.
Sure.
>> Do we have a full list of
the publications that came
out of Sher Ali Khan's press?
>> Elham Bakhtary: So there's a lot
of speculation about certain works
that were produced, but
have been destroyed.
So there are lists -- I have
a list of works that do exist.
Robert McChesney at NYU has compiled
a list of works that were produced
from the time of Emir Sher Ali Khan.
But there are also other works that
we don't have any extant copies
of them, but people speculate --
especially Afghan scholars speculate
them to have been produced.
And I have some information on that
material, if you're interested,
and I could share it with you.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: With respect to
using [inaudible] as the [inaudible]
for propaganda, was he also
pushing for reform, organization,
changes in the society, and
if so, what were the changes
that he was trying to
[inaudible] from the richest issue?
What social, economic, cultural
changes was he pushing for?
>> Elham Bakhtary: Emir
Sher Ali Khan is trying
to really just create a central
authority in Afghanistan.
So the Afghan kingdom was really
founded on a series of partnerships
with other chieftains
in the Durrani tribe.
And so there was real no -- there
was not really any central kind
of leadership throughout
the country.
There was much autonomy divided
between the different tribes,
and also between the different
brothers, even, in the royal family.
And he's trying to centralize the
entire country, and he's trying
to do this primarily
through an army.
And in "Shamsa Nihar,"
he tries to dress this
up as creating civilization,
as educating people.
But when you really look
at it, the civilization
that he's talking about, the
education that he's talking about,
the production in arts and crafts,
it all has to do with the military.
When he talks about education,
for example, and creating scholars
out of Afghans, he's just
talking about sending them
to these military schools
that he's established,
and having them learn
military formations,
and drills along the
British-Indian model.
When he talks about arts and crafts,
right, bringing manufacturing,
he's just talking about
the factories
that he's established
to produce weapons.
Okay? So even though he's trying
to dress it up as civilization,
what he's really just talking about
is this militaries that he's trying
to create, to consolidate
his authority
over the entirety of Afghanistan.
>> Hiram Dinavari: Okay.
Thank you, everyone, for coming.
Thank you, Elham, for a
wonderful presentation.
And the work continues.
As we digitize, the material
becomes available online
on various platforms,
and hopefully a library.
Soon, people from around the world
can chime and use this material.
And Elham, we look forward to
having you come and work more
with our Afghan materials that are
now being processed as we speak.
Thank you very much.
>> Elham Bakhtary:
Thank you, everybody.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.